uh pastor is that it
one more one more who's that person
oh my good brother yes
yes if you have an art with your brother
yes and you go to him and you apologize
and he says i i don't accept your
apology
but what is the state of that good
question
there are a lot of problems in churches
because members will not apologize to
each other they prefer to go gossip
instead of following matthew 18 15 to
17. moreover if thy brother shall
trespass against thee go and tell him
his fault between thee and him
alone
if we would do that step one
we would cut out a lot of interpersonal
problems in the church but we call our
friends we text this person we skype
that person we you know
and we discuss it
and damage the person
the biblical method is always best
if someone is offended you go to that
person
it provides release for you and a chance
for the person to be free from the guilt
if the person does not accept you then
there's nothing you can do but you can
try again
because jesus said 70 times seven he was
willing to forgive
you can try again but if it's clear the
person is not you have done your part
and god accepts that because the person
is as much required by god to accept
your confession or your apology as you
are to give it
both things must work
but some people they wrap their arms and
no i'm not accepting your apology that
is not of god
the greatest offense is sin and god
accepts our apologies when we confess
we're to be like him all right that's
the end of it my my brothers and sisters
may god bless you
listen to me carefully
study the word of god
please
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
the scriptures are the chief agency in
the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctified him through thy
truth
thy word is true hello white souls if
studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart
subduing
every unholy attribute
when christ comes back he raises the
dead
with the word
until then he will sustain us by the
word and take time to read the writings
of ellen white please
god bless you
wherever you are if i come across your
mind please say lord
put your words in that man's mouth god
bless you
[Music]